OVERALL. ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BATES BACKER FORTRESS BRADFORD
BY ADAM CORTEZ THE TALLY DODD
YOU'RE AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG WEST
HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
. LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MULLIN MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A CHILL OUT BOTH
. PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER TURN ON BURKE BY CASKEY
WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE REAL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR WIENER AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY CENTER
ALLEN IF I CAN ASK ALL OF OUR
GUESTS IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
RISE THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
MERCIFUL AND GRACIOUS GOD. WE
BELIEVE THAT EACH ONE OF US IS
THE SPARK OF YOUR DIVINE LIGHTS
FILLED WITH THE POTENTIAL TO
EMANATE YOUR SPIRIT OF LOVE. JOY
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION FOR THE
COMMON GOOD FOR THE BUILDING UP
OF OUR WORLD. AS WE TRANSMIT THE
BEST OF OURSELVES TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND THE MINISTRY OF
EDUCATION. HELP US TO EDUCATE
EACH INDIVIDUAL ABOUT THE
DIGNITY AND WORTH. OF EVERY
PERSON. MAY WE AS A SOCIETY
COMMIT TO PROVIDING ALL CHILDREN
WITH THE RESOURCES SPIRITUAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL. AND ETHICAL AS
WELL AS PHYSICAL AND
INTELLECTUAL. TO ENABLE THEM TO
REACH THEIR HIGHEST POTENTIAL.
MAY WE INSPIRE THEM TO
CONTRIBUTE THEIR GIFTS AND
TALENTS TO CREATING COMMUNITIES
OF JUSTICE. TRUTH FORGIVENESS
AND PEACE. IN THIS CHALLENGING
TIMES GIVE US THE COURAGE TO
WITNESS TO THE POSSIBILITY OF
HOPE AND TRANSFORMATION AND ARE
ANXIOUS AND SUFFERING WORLD. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
MEMBERS ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF APRIL FOUR
THROUGH SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WILL BE APPROVED AND CORRECTED.
THAT'S CORRECT BY THE MINUTE
CLERK. MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE WILL START WITH THE SECOND
READING FILE MEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS NINE FIFTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN THIRTY FIVE
MINUTES. FOURTEEN NINETEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN NINETEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT WITH THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY THE SECOND
READING FILE WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE SHOW BOSS.
AS DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES PRIOR TO
THIS ROLE SHE HAD BEEN SERVING
AS UNDERSECRETARY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY SHE IS ALSO
FORMER SENATE STAFF HAVING
SERVED AS CONSULTANT TO THE
SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL SIX
FUNNY UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BATES
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR PAN. THAT IS AYE
TO OF THE CONFIRMATION THE SHELL
BASS TO BE DIRECTOR OF THE PARK
HEALTHCARE SERVICES- WE ARE
UNDERGOING A VERY IMPORTANT-
TRANSFORMATION MEDIC HOW WITH
COLLEEN AND MANY OTHER.
ACTIVITIES AS WELL WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT ON THIS FLOOR IN
VARIOUS COMMITTEES- SHE IS A
PERSON WHO I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT- IN STUDY- CABLE IN
TERMS OF THE- THIS. AND SO I
ALSO URGE AND I VOTE FOR HER
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BAKER.
PORCHES I BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
AYE PROTESTING AYE DOLLY. DODD
HI TO RUSSELL I EGGMAN I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HURTS I WAS
. HURTADO JONES I KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO. NEWMAN
I NIELSEN. A CHOI BOGUE. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE I'M BURKE
. I WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE
WILK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY BAKER. I DALLY
GROVE WESA I HER TADO. LIMON MAN
I NIELSEN. OTOBO WELL. ITHIRTY
TWO KNOWS ONE THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO SURVEYS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF MARKLE MEECH AS
UNDERSECRETARY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY PRIOR TO THIS
ROLE HE HAD BEEN SERVING THE
AGENCY OF SECRETARY FOR THE
OFFICE OF PROGRAM AND FISCAL
AFFAIRS HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL SIX ON
A FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BATES MEMBERS DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE SENATOR PAM THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF MARCO MAGIC TO
BE UNDERSECRETARY HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES YEARS PREVENT
CAPABLE IN THIS ROLE IN TURN AND
LEADING MANY VERY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES OR THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO IN
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIS AND THE SENATE SO I TO-
CHECK CONFIRMATION THANK. THANK
YOU CENTER MEMBERS FOR
DISCUSSION OR TO SEEING AND
HEARING THEM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BAKER I
FORGES HI BRADFORD AYE CABRERA
AYE CORTESE AYE DOLLY. DODD I
AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
WESO HI FOR TOTTENHAM. HI JOE. I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MEN. I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A
TROUBLED HI PAM. I PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I
STERN AYE NUMBER I CASTING. I
WIENER. I WILK. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS ONE THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF BRANDON MCCARTY
AS DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR PROGRAMS
IN FISCAL AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY PRIOR TO THIS
POSITION HE WAS SERVING THE
AGENCY AS AN ASSISTANT SECRETARY
HE IS ALSO FORMER SENATE STAFF
HAVING SERVED AS A CONSULTANT
FOR THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL SIXTH
ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BAKER. I PORCHES I
BRADFORD. I HAVE A ITEM I
PROTECTING I DALY. DODD ARE YOU
THERE ALSO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
WAS SO. HURTADO HI JONES HI
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO
MAN I NEWMAN I. NIELSEN AYE A
CHOI BOGUE HI PAM AYE PORTANTINO
. I ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI I'M BURKE. HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DALLY GROWTH WESO I LIMÓN WILK I
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
SENATOR PORTANTINO BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO
AN ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS.
CENTER PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- I
PRESENT SB NINE EIGHTEEN WHICH
CLEANS UP OBSOLETE PENAL CODE
PROVISIONS AND UPDATES FIREARM
RELATED REFERENCES THERE ARE
CURRENTLY A NUMBER OF OUT OF
DATE CROSS REFERENCES ARRIVING
FROM COLLECTED PASSAGE OF RECENT
FIREMAN FIREARM LEGISLATION
INCLUDING LEGISLATION AUTHORED
BY OUR CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL-
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
CORRECT THE SPECIFIC CROSS
REFERENCES THE FIRST UPDATE IS
RICK REGARDING THE PREVIOUSLY
ESTABLISHED BAKE IT BASIC
AMMUNITION ELIGIBILITY CHECK FEE
AND STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
PERTAINING TO THE DOJ'S WORK
FREE OF COST. THIS CAN UPDATE IS
REGARDING THE PREVIOUSLY
ESTABLISHED A PRECURSOR PART
FEES AND STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
PERTAINING TO THE DOJ'S RECOVERY
OF COSTS FOR PRECURSOR PART
TRANSACTIONS AND THEN THE THIRD
UPDATED IN REGARDS TO LICENSE
FIREARM DEALER LICENSE I MEAN IF
THE BENDERS WHO SHALL
AUTOMATICALLY BE DEEMED FIREARM
PRECURSOR PART YOURSELF A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER POINT MEMBERS.
FOR DEBATE. C. AND HEARING NONE
. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES NO BAKER. I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. I FOR
TESTING AYE DALY DODD I TORONTO
I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I REQUEST SO
I HER TADO. JONES. NO KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA. I LIMON
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO CONTROL
VOTE NO HAN AYE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER. I STERN HI
I'M BURKE. I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER I WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLY GROVE HER
TADO. LIMÓN ROTH. RUBIO I. WELL. TWENTY EIGHT NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU ALL TO GIVE A
BIG SENATE WELCOME TO SOME OF
CENTER WHITE HOUSE THESE
NEIGHBORS FROM MARJORY DRIVE IN
FREMONT WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. WE ARE
STILL ON SENATE THIRD READING
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR WIENER
REJECTED PRESENT YOUR BILL.
MANDAMUS PLEASE READ FOLLOWING
THIRTY FOUR. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
OH SIX BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO RESENTENCING CENTER
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RUNNING PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES-
S. B. ELEVEN OH SIX THE FRESH
START ACT I WILL HELP PEOPLE TO
CLEAR THEIR CRIMINAL RECORDS BY
ENSURING THAT OUTSTANDING
RESTITUTION AND RESTITUTION
FINES ARE NOT A BARRIER TO
EXPUNGE. ARE CURRENTLY PEOPLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE FREQUENTLY
DENIED EXPUNGEMENT EVEN IF
THEY'RE OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY OUTSTANDING RESTITUTION AND
RESTITUTION FINES RESTITUTION
THAT IS OFTEN THE ONLY THING
HOLDING SOMEONE BACK FROM
CLEARING THE RECORD AND FINING.
AND HOUSING- ADDITIONALLY WHEN
SETTING RESTITUTION AMOUNTS
QUARTER NOT REQUIRED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT A PERSON'S ABILITY
TO PAY THAT RESTITUTION THIS
MEANS THAT VICTIMS OF CRIME WHO
WERE AWARDED RESTITUTION
OVERWHELMINGLY RECEIVED EITHER
NOTHING OR A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THE RESTITUTION. BECAUSE OF THE
TENANTS SIMPLY LACKS THE
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY PAYER.
CARLAW COURTS TO THAN A REQUEST
FOR EXPUNGEMENT EVEN IF THE
INDIVIDUAL IS OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
IF THEY HAVE ANY OUTSTANDING
UNPAID RESTITUTION. ON A CORK
AND THEN I EXPANSION ON THIS
BASIS EVEN IF THE DEFENDANT IS
LIVING IN POVERTY. THIS KIND OF
BARRIER TO REENTRY DOES NOT
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
SOMEONE WILL PAY THE RESTITUTION
IN FACT BLOCKING SOMEONE FROM
CLEARING THEIR RECORDS MAKES IT
EVEN LESS LIKELY THAT THEY'LL
EVER BE IN A POSITION TO PAY THE
RESTITUTION. I WANT TO BE VERY
VERY CLEAR. S. B. ELEVEN OH SIX
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE A PERSON'S RESTITUTION
THE AMOUNT THAT A PERSON WAS A
RESTITUTION THIS BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH. THE RESTITUTION OWED- NOR
DOES IT IMPACT THE COURT'S
ABILITY TO ENFORCE RESTITUTION
ORDERS IT SIMPLY. PROVIDES THAT
UNPAID RESTITUTION WILL NOT BE A
BARRIER. TO EXPLAINS RUN-
SERVICE SOMEONE CAN RE ENTER.
SOCIETY AND GET THEIR LIFE BACK
ON TRACK COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER MEMBERS
JUST. AND OR DEBATE SO NIELSEN.
AT A PRESS LADIES IN GENTLEMEN
SENATE HOW MUCH MORE DISTRICTS
CAN THIS LEGISLATURE KEEP UPON
OUR VICTIMS. THE OF. WHO HAVE TO
SUFFERED A LOSS OF SOME KIND AT
THE HANDS OF A CRIB OFFENDERS.
AND NOW THEY WON'T EVEN MAYBE
HAVE TO PAY RESTITUTION. I'VE
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME AND FOR
MOST OF HISTORY AT LEAST MY
HISTORY. THESE INDIVIDUALS NEVER
PAID RESTITUTION ANYWAY. AND
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION MADE LITTLE
ATTEMPT TO EVER RECOVER THE
RESTITUTION- OWED TO VICTIMS
VICTIMS MEANING SOMETHING
HAPPENED TO THEM THEIR LIVES OR
THEIR PROPERTY. AND NOW WE DON'T
REQUIRE MAIL. WE LESSEN THE
SENTENCES FOR ALMOST EVERYTHING
EVEN FOR THE WORST OFFENDERS. WE
DON'T PUT PEOPLE IN PRISON VERY
MUCH ANYMORE. AND NOW WE'RE
GONNA THE NIGHT RESTITUTION.
WHICH MOST CRIMINAL OFFENDERS
HAVE NOT AND WILL NOT PAY ANYWAY
ALWAYS JUST REMOVING THE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. WOW I SO
WHAT DOES THAT SAY TO THE JUDGES
NOW YOU'RE ON THE SPOT HUH. THE
DISRESPECT OUR VICTIMS LIKE OUR
LEGISLATURE HAS DISRESPECTED OUR
VICTIMS ANOTHER LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN I URGE A NO VOTE THANK
YOU CENTER NELSON SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WHAT THE RESTITUTION
COSTS ACTUALLY GO TOWARD THIS IS
NOT- YOU KNOW SOME BIG PAY OUT
THAT A VICTIM GETS THE USER THE
MONEY PAID IN RESTITUTION GOES
TO THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO PAY FOR THINGS LIKE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS TO PAY FOR
THINGS LIKE IF THEY HAD TO RE
LOCATE. BECAUSE THEIR PROPERTY
THEIR HOME WAS DAMAGED- BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW OUT OF FEAR FOR THEIR
OWN SAFETY THEY HAD TO RELOCATE
THEIR FAMILIES THIS IS USER BIG
EXPENSES THE VICTIMS FAMILIES
ARE VICTIMS THEMSELVES MUST
ENCOURAGE AND THAT IS WHAT IS
BEING AFFECTED HERE. I'M THE
OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS. THE MADE BY THE-
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO SAY. I'M
IN THE THEY SAID THE MANY
EXPUNGEMENT IN RELATED POST
CONVICTION REHABILITATION
STATUTES PROVIDE CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS. FINISHED WITH THEIR
SENTENCES A CLEAN SLATE. TO
APPLY FOR JOBS GET BENEFITS AND
GENERALLY RE INTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY AS PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS.
AND THAT IS A USEFUL BENEFIT
PROMOTE THEM IN SOCIETY BUT-
TAKING AWAY THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THESE DEFENDANTS COMPLETE THE
RESTITUTION ORDER TO VICTIMS. IN
THE FINE THAT THEY MUST PAY
BEFORE OBTAINING RELIEF FAVORS
THESE DEFENDANTS AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE VICTIMS. AND IT PLACES A
HARD STOP IN THE FACE OF TRUE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. THE COURTS
HEARING THESE MOTIONS ALREADY
HAVE THE DISCRETION TO GRANT OR
DENY THEM. EVEN IF RESTITUTION
IS UNPAID. TAKING THAT
DISCRETION COMPLETELY WAY NOT
ONLY MAKES A SOCIAL CHOICE. IN
FAVOR OF DEFENDANTS OVER VICTIMS
BUT ALSO IN FAVOR DEFENDANTS
OVER THE JUDGMENT OF THE COURT
IN THE STATE. REMOVING
DISCRETION TO CONSIDER
RESTITUTION FINES AFFECTS NOT
ONLY THE COURTS. BUT IT AFFECTS
VICTOR. DIRECTLY IN INDIRECTLY
BECAUSE THOSE FIND HELP PAY THE
STATE'S VICTIM COMPENSATION. AND
DIRECTORS TO XIN TO VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT WHEN YOU'RE VOTING
ON THIS BILL AND I WOULD- URGE
IN NOVA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MELINDA SAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW
THE PROBLEM HERE IS. WHEN THE
COURT ORDERS RESTITUTION AS PART
OF THE SENTENCING PROCESS. AND
THE INDIVIDUAL HAS COMPLETED ALL
OF THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS
NECESSARY TO FINISH THIS EXCEPT
PAY THE RESTITUTION. MORE TIMES
THAN NOT THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING A JOB. IN
THIS ARGUMENT THAT MY FRIENDS
WHO ARE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ARE
MAKING IS RATHER CIRCUITOUS IT'S
CIRCULAR. VICTIMS NEED THE MONEY
KORUGAR RESTITUTION YOU SHOULD
BE PAYING RESTITUTION BUT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CHANGE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO EXPLAINS THE SENTENCE
SO YOU CAN GET A JOB AND PAY THE
RESTITUTION. AND HOW IN THE
WORLD IS AT WORK. AND WE CAN SAY
JUDGES AND I HAVE FRIENDS THAT
OUR JUDGES HAVE THE DISCRETION
TO DO THAT BUT LISTEN TO THE
PRESSURE THAT WE PUT ON
OURSELVES HERE ONE SIDEOR THE
OTHER. THE PRESSURE IS PUT ON A
JUDGE IN A COURT. AND WE EXPECT
THE JUDGE TO WITHSTAND THE
PRESSURE AND DO THE RIGHT THING
SOMETIMES THEY DO BUT SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T BECAUSE JUDGES STAND
FOR REELECTION AS WELL. AND THEY
CANNOT ENGAGE IN THE TYPE OF
PARTISAN POLITICAL CAMPAIGNING
BUT WE ARE ACCUSTOMED TO DEFEND
THE POSITIONS THAT WE TAKE. IN
THIS CHAMBER SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK. WHEN A PERSON
HAS SATISFIED THE SENTENCE OF
THE COURT HAS IMPOSED FOR THE
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED. THE
AND I'M I THINK VICTIMS DESERVE
RESTITUTION I THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THE MONEY GETS
TO THE VICTIMS. BUT INDIVIDUALS
DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET A
JOB TO EARN THE MONEY. TO PAY
THE RESTITUTION. ORDER SO I
REASONABLE THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER ROF MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE CENTER
WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
SAID IT IN THE BEGINNING BUT
APPARENTLY I NEED TO SAY IT
AGAIN. THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY
WAY REDUCE THE RESTITUTION IS
OWED BY ONE PENNY THE BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH HOW MUCH YOU
ARE IF THIS IS SIGNED INTO LAW
ANYONE WHO OWES RESTITUTION WILL
CONTINUE TO- THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RESTITUTION WHICH CAN'T BE
DISCHARGED IN BANKRUPTCY. BY THE
WAY. SO TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
SOMEHOW IMPACTS PEOPLE. PEOPLE'S
OBLIGATION TO PAY RESTITUTION IS
SIMPLY FALSE WHAT THIS BILL DOES
DO IS TO SAY WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
HELP YOU GET BACK ON YOUR FEET
SO THAT YOU CAN GET YOUR LIFE
BACK TOGETHER. AND IF PEOPLE
CAN'T GET THEIR LIFE BACK
TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
GOTTEN EXPUNGEMENT. AND THEY
CAN'T GET A GOOD JOB MAYBE THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE HOUSING. BEN
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR A LOT OF THINGS AND THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PAY. RESTITUTION AND LET'S BE
CLEAR OVERWHELMINGLY PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR. THEY WERE
PROBABLY POOR GOING INTO PRISON
AND THEY'RE DEFINITELY ALMOST
CERTAINLY POOR COMING OUT OF
PRISON AND TO SAY TO THEM YOU OF
THIS RESTITUTION AND WE'RE NOT
EVEN GOING TO HELP YOU GET YOUR
LIFE BACK TOGETHER BECAUSE
YOU'RE POOR AND YOU CAN'T PAY
THE RESTITUTION SO YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN YOUR
RECORD AND SO YOU'RE NEVER GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET A GOOD JOB.
HOW DOES THAT HELP VICTIMS THAT
DOES NOT HELP THE VICTIMS THAT
HARMS VICTIMS- THIS IS A GOOD
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AUTO. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER.
HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD I HAVE A
BETTER. CORTEZ'S I DALY. DODD
THE RUSSELL I EGGMAN I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI WESA I FURTADO. NO
JONES NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE LIMÓN FIRE I MELENDEZ
NO MAN. NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO
CONTROL OF BOTH NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE ON BURKE HI
MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CABALLERO I. DALLY DODD. GROWTH
LIMÓN MEN I WELL. GLAZER I DON'T
KNOW. FIVE THREE SEVEN KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WERE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY EIGHT SENATOR CORTESE. I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CORTEZ C. RELATIVE TO
EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY
CALIFORNIA CENTER CORTESE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I'M
PROUD TO INTRODUCE US ARE
SEVENTY SEVEN ALONG WITH SENATOR
WINNER TO HONOR EDUCATION AND
SHARING DAY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE A RABBI MENDEL WIN WIN
FILLED FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR OF
THE BOUGHT HOUSE OF SENATE
DISTRICT FIFTEEN FOR WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICES ARE BRINGING
FOR THIS RESOLUTION IT ALSO LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE RABBI MINDY COHEN
CHIEF RABBI OF SACRAMENTO WHO'S
HERE TODAY. EDUCATION ASSURING
DAYS ABOUT CREATING
CONVERSATIONS IT'S ABOUT THE
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. AROUND THE DINNER
TABLE THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE
WITH OUR STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOMS. IN THE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAVE. A GOOD. DAY IN AND DAY
OUT THEY COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF OUR
YOUNG ONES OVER THE LAST FOUR
DECADES THE US CONGRESS TO SET
ASIDE EDUCATION ASSURING DAY.
AND IS PROCLAIMED ANNUALLY BY
PRESIDING U. S. PRESIDENTS FROM
BOTH PARTIES. ON THE BIRTHDAY.
OF RABBI. MENACHEM MENDEL
SCHNEERSON. KNOWN AS THE RIVER.
WHO IS ONE OF THE LEADING GLOBAL
ADVOCATES FOR THE ADVANCEMENT.
OF EDUCATION. WHILE HE
CONCENTRATED HIS EFFORTS ON
REBUILDING AND ENERGIZING THE
GLOBAL JEWISH COMMUNITY AFTER
THE DEVASTATION OF THE
HOLOCAUST. YOU PAY GREAT
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS OF ALL
HUMANITY. ON APRIL TWELFTH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE MARKED THE
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTIETH
ANIVERSARY OF THE REBELS BIRTH.
FOR MORE THAN FORTY YEARS THE
PRESIDENT I'D STATES HAS
RECOGNIZED AND HONORED THE REV
HIS VISION EACH YEAR ON THAT DAY
BY PROCLAIM IT EDUCATION. DAY
USA. EDUCATION ENSURING DAYS
FOUR DAYS BEFORE THE JEWISH
FESTIVAL OF PASSOVER IN TRIBUTE.
TO HIS COMMITMENT TO TEACHING
NEXT GENERATION OF AMERICANS THE
VALUES THAT MAKE OUR COUNTRY
STRONGER IT TODAY THAT PROVIDES
AMERICANS THE OPPORTUNITY PAUSE
AND RECOGNIZE A RESPONSIBILITY.
TO ENSURE THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE THE FOUNDATION NECESSARY TO
LEAD LIVES RICH IN PURPOSE AND
FULFILLMENT. THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR THE ROBOT INTRODUCE
THE CHARITY CAMPAIGN A
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN TO TRAIN US
ALL TO BECOME GIVERS. TO HONOR
THIS CAMPAIGN OFFICE WILL BE
STRICKEN WITH OTHER SENATE
OFFICES YO CHARITY BOXES TO
ENCOURAGE GENEROSITY IN GIVING
TO CHARITY. EVERY DAY AS WELL AS
A CARD. EXPLAINING THE MEANING
BEHIND THIS DAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS IN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CHARACTERIZED AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF US ARE
SEVENTY SEVEN. EDUCATION AND
SHARING DAY IS A DAY FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
EDUCATION FOR ALL. AND THE POWER
OF LEARNING TO BUILD STRONG
MORAL CHARACTER IN YOUNG PEOPLE.
THROUGH EDUCATION AND SHARING
DAY WE HONOR THE LIFE AND
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE LUBAVITCHER
REBBE RABBI MENACHEM MENDEL
SCHNEERSON. A LIFELONG ADVOCATE
FOR UNIVERSAL EDUCATION ONWHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HIS ONE HUNDRED
TWENTIETH BIRTHDAY. OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS LIFE HE FOUND THAT
OVER FIVE THOUSAND EDUCATION
AVERAGE CENTERS TO PROVIDE
HUMANITARIAN AID AND SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PEOPLE AROUND THE
GLOBE. RABBI SCHNEERSON FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION IS A
CRITICAL AVENUE FOR PROMOTING
COMPASSION EQUITY AND JUSTICE TO
YOUNG PEOPLE TODAY. IS A HOLD
ESPECIALLY GREAT SIGNAL AS ANTI
SEMITIC INCIDENTS AND OTHER
FORMS OF HATE ARE ON THE RISE
ACROSS THE US AND EVEN IN OUR
SCHOOLS. IN FLORIDA FOR INSTANCE
THE RECENTLY PASSED ON STAGE A
BILL PROMOTES A CULTURE OF
INTOLERANCE AND EXCLUSION. IN
FLORIDA SCHOOLS OVER A DOZEN
STATES ARE POISED TO PASS THEIR
OWN FORM OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
FOLLOW SUIT. IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUST MUST WORK TO MAKE OUR
SCHOOLS ACCESSIBLE AND SAFE FOR
ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
RACE. GENDER IDENTITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION RELIGION OR ANY
OTHER ASPECT OF THEIR IDENTITY
EDUCATION AND SHARING DAY IS A
CHANCE TO REMIND OURSELVES. THAT
EDUCATION AND SHARING WE'RE NOT
SIMPLY VALUES BUT INTENTIONAL
ACTIONS TO BE DONE AGAIN AND
AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
WIENER MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER CORTESE
WHICH ABOUT CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BOATS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL THE ANYONE OBJECT USING A
YOU. WELL PARDON ME WE HAVE A
CELL THE ROLL CALL SO MA'AM SIR
PLEASE CALL ROLL. OUR I ARE TO
LET FIVE AT I BATES AYE BACK.
FIVE FORTUS I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DALY. DODD FIVE ZERO SEVEN I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG HI WESTERN I
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA AYE LIMÓN
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ. AYE MIN
AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A TROLL
BOTH I PAM. I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI VACANCY I WIENER
AYE WILK I WAS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE SENATOR GONZALEZ MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY H. WHICH WILL
DESIGNATE THE WEEK OF APRIL
ELEVENTH THROUGH APRIL
SEVENTEENTH AS CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK WHICH
ALSO HAPPENS TO FALL ON THE-CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR THIS IS A
TIME OF REMEMBRANCE AND RENEWAL
AS WE LOOK BACK IN REMEMBRANCE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT ON APRIL
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. THE COMMUNIST FORCES OF
THE COME I ROUGE LED BY PAUL
POTE SEIZE POWER CAMBODIA AND
BEGAN A REIGN OF TERROR THAT
TARGETED ACADEMICS PROFESSIONALS
INTELLECTUALS RELIGIOUS LEADERS
AND ETHNIC MINORITIES AND SOUGHT
TO DESTROY CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS BUDDHIST TEMPLES SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES DANCE AND MUSIC. AND
LESS THAN FOUR YEARS OF RULE THE
CA MY ROUGE MURDERED NEARLY TWO
MILLION CAMBODIANS ROUGHLY 20%
OF THE POPULATION THROUGH FORCED
LABOR PRISON CAMPS IN EXECUTION
WHAT BECAME KNOWN AS THE KILLING
FIELDS. AFTER THE OVERTHROW OF
THE COME I REACH ONE HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND CAMBODIANS
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
AS REFUGEES IN A BECOME AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE FABRIC OF
OUR STATE CALIFORNIA IS NOW HOME
TO A LARGE PROPORTION OF
CAMBODIANS AND THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN THE SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY THREE IS PROUD TO HAVE
THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY.
RECOGNIZING CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE
MEMORIAL WE WILL HONOR THE
SURVIVORS AND THEIR DESCENDANTS
FOR THEIR COURAGE IN THE FACE OF
TERROR AND FOR THEIR CONTINUED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE AND
OUR COUNTRY AND REMEMBRANCE OF
THE SOLEMN OCCASION ALL
SIMULTANEOUSLY SEPARATE
CELEBRATING THE NEW YEAR I HAVE
SHARED WITH EACH SENATOR THE
GIFT OF A FRAMED ARTWORK
DESIGNED BY SAN SEPARATE OF. A
COMMUNITY LEADER IN THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY IN THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THE
CENTRE GONZALEZ MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER MAN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS THERE'S A TO RISE AND
FALL SUPPORT SR SEVENTY EIGHT
AND THE ONE I THINK MY GOOD
FRIENDS LONG BEACH FOR BRING
THIS IMPORTANT RESOLUTION FOR.
THE CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
STAND THE- PORTS OF REMEMBERING
THE HISTORY PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
HERE TO TELL. AND- TELL. THAT
THEY BRING WITH THEM THAT
HISTORY THAT ACTUALLY COMES.
OFTENTIMES FROM ACTUALLY ATTACKS
OF OUR OWN COUNTRY IN ASIA THAT
THEN BROUGHT THEM OVER HERE. THE
CAMBODIANS HAVE PLAYED A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- THEY'VE
CONTRIBUTED GREATLY BUT THEY DID
COME FROM UNFORTUNATELY AN
EXPERIENCE OF TRAGEDY- THAT.
BACK IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY AND
WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT AND SO
THAT THIS RESOLUTION IS A VERY
IMPORTANT. STATEMENT AS TO THE
HISTORY THAT IMPORTANT HISTORY
WITH THAT WE NEED TO REMEMBER.
AND CONTINUE TO BRING FOR A
HISTORY THAT ACTUALLY IS NOT
ONLY OF COURSE RELEVANT TO THEIR
OWN COUNTRY AND- ON HISTORY. BUT
ALSO TO- OUR OUR TERROR COUNTRY
AS WE CONTINUE TO BATTLE
UNFORTUNATELY. ACTS OF GENOCIDE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD SO AGAIN I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON SR SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK. HE SAID THANK YOU
CENTER PAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS THIS IS YOU ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ANYONE
WANT THAT TO BE REMOVED. SEEING
AND HEARING NO ONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE ITEM.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BAKER. I
PORCHES FIVE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CORTESE AYE ALLEN
DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HER TADO I
JONES. I KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI LIMÓN MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN
. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN HI
NUMBER NINE HI WE HAVE SKI I
WIENER. FIVE WILK OIL TO MEMBERS
DALLY GROWTH WESTERN I. LIMÓN
WILK. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
CENTER ALLEN FOR A PURPOSE YOU
RISE I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT IT
REQUEST THE AUTHOR JESSE GABRIEL
THE WE REMOVE SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR FILE IN A MAY THIRTY EIGHT
FROM AN ACTIVE FILE THE DESK
WILL NOTE THANK YOU CENTER ALAN.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS IT IS NOW TIME
FOR COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE
BURKE BEFORE WE GET TO COMMITTEE
ENOUGH FOR PURPOSE RISE A
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT. DOESN'T
VERY GOOD I WAS VERY GOOD PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MEMBERS OF A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE GOOD NEWS
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE WON'T BE
GOING TILL NINE O'CLOCK TOMORROW
NIGHT WE WILL BE STARTING AT TEN
AM THE- THANK YOU SIR I'M BURKE
CENTER CORTESE. LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT- WILL
BE MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MINUTES AFTER
GERMAN OF THE SESSION THANK YOU
MATTER PRESENT. THANK YOU SERRA
CORTESE CENTER HUESO. AND THE
CHAMBER. NRG TELECOMMUNICATIONS
AND UTILITIES WILL BE MEDIAN-
AFTER THE ADJOURNMENT OF SENATE
HERE IN THE LAST TWENTY MINUTES
AFTER THE ADJOURNMENTS CENTER
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO IF THERE
IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER
ACTIONS THE DESK IT'S CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION WILL
BE THIS THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT NINE
AM. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GREAT REST TODAY
MEMBERS.